the head of the white house chronovirus  task force dr deborah burks  is calling the coronavirus pandemic the  worst event  in american history today much of  california is back in lockdown  that state recorded more than 30 000 new  cases in a single day yesterday  that is the highest single day total so  far in any state  here in nevada casinos and restaurants  still have a 25 percent capacity limit  nurse janet baum says her hospital up in  reno has  never been busier than it is right now  never in my wildest nightmares would i  ever have thought  that we would ever see something that  would be killing this many people  nevada now leads the country when it  comes to the number of people  hospitalized with coronavirus  per capita